hey get this we're taking over Comic Con  for the fifth year in a row  Conan Con is blowing you away in the  past but this year it's going to be even  bigger and better than before you know  why because we're bringing back our at  Conan Con Instagram account and also  I've got this you want tickets and Conan  Kahn has got tickets you want Funko pop  figures gonna con has got Funko pop  figures you want random things to happen  while I snap a bunch of times anyway  follow at conan kannada instagram for  tickets  Funko figure special guests and more  it's gonna be a great go away disappear  so the Infinity Gauntlet itself is just  a glove it houses the Infinity stones  which in fact is where the real power  comes to and hammers that created the  digital cameras now